KATIE COURIC (VOICEOVER):
is shifting before our eyes.
Race you to the top, Mike.
(VOICEOVER) Big changes--
Hi, Henry.
HENRY: Hi, Katie.
KATIE COURIC (VOICEOVER):
--big challenges--
I hate to admit it, but
I probably am prejudiced.
KATIE COURIC (VOICEOVER):
--in a world that's
more complicated than ever.
How many of you
have been chipped?
That kind of creeps me out.
[laughter]
Would you consider
yourself a neo-Nazi?
I would non.
I'd consider myself
a white nationalist,
and I would consider myself
a member of the alt right.
We're teaching kids that
girls are second-class citizens.
HR has become HER.
You think this
was a hate crime?
Without a doubt.
She died because of her hijab.
American Muslims are
shaped by American culture.
Tech addiction, there
are a lot of positives,
but there's some negative too.
I want to be your best
friend and much more.
Maybe not the much more part.
But the friends part,
I'm cool with that.
(VOICEOVER) It seems that
everyone has something to say.
Whose streets?
Our streets.
- Whose streets?
- Our street.
KATIE COURIC (VOICEOVER): But
nobody's really listening.
What about my rights?
Don't I have rights?
KATIE COURIC
(VOICEOVER): Join me
on a journey as I
criss-cross the country,
meeting all kinds of
Americans, where they
live, work, pray, and play.
Who are we?
What do we stand for?
We're trying to get paid
what white women get paid.
KATIE COURIC (VOICEOVER):
Where are we going,
and how do we make
things better?
This is [inaudible].
She's running for city council.
Hey, how are you?
KATIE COURIC (VOICEOVER):
Searching for truth--
You actually think you're
part of the cleaning crew?
Yes.
KATIE COURIC (VOICEOVER):
--looking for understanding--
How would you describe what
it's like to be Muslim?
- Hard.
- Hard?
(VOICEOVER) --getting to
the heart of the matter.
To have such
conversations, you have to be
willing to be uncomfortable.
KATIE COURIC (VOICEOVER):
--in "America Inside Out."